un déplacement sur la réussite scolaire
mais aussi sur l'emploi présent aux
mureaux en début de semaine emmanuel
macron est venu s'adresser aux habitants
des quartiers populaires et pour leur
redonner un peu d'espoir le chantier est
vaste plus de 250 mille jeunes quittent
chaque année l'école sans qualification
dans certains quartiers comme ici on a
un tout qui est bien plus élevé donc je
pense que l'une des batailles forte
qu'il faut de mener pour l'égalité des
chances c'est d'arriver à réduire de
façon forte 7
cette discrimination là parmi les
propositions du candidat dans marche des
effectifs allégés dans les zones en
éducation prioritaire avec un maximum de
douze élèves par classe vous avez des
élèves dont les parents accumule les
difficultés économiques ou sociales dans
les parents parfois ne maîtrisent pas
bien le français et qui ont donc besoin
d'un plus grand encadrement pour bien
maîtriser la lecture l'écriture et le
calcul
autre mesure généralisée la lutte contre
les discriminations ou encore accompagné
l'emploi dans les quartiers avec des
allègements de charge allant jusqu'à
quinze mille euros
les jeunes que j'ai pu entendre cet
après midi me l'ont confirmé
lorsqu'on veut réussir au sortir du
quartier il faut devenir footballeur
acteur de cinéma au comique maintenant
il faut pouvoir devenir professeur
d'université
entrepreneurs cadres supérieurs reste à
convaincre les électeurs de ces
quartiers populaires dans cette ville
des mureaux l'abstention atteignait 31 %
au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle en 2012 contre 20%
seulement au niveau national